give it up the Magnificent Chris thank
you very much and do not worry I was not
expecting me to look like this either
hello I am Chris I have a freestyle
rapper
whoops let it starts in freestyle
rappers rap man upon the spot based
entirely on audience suggestions so when
I ask everyone head to think of a word a
topic or a phrase you would like to hear
a rap about there are three rules are
going to give you number one no food
number two no animals that the most
common things our friends think of
they're way too easy
number three nothing too obvious in
general don't say brexit that's a truck
those out all the time right I'll never
take a sense gesture twice it's not fun
it's not exciting the best suggestion
ever ninth-century crop rotation
anti-intellectual peak if you wish we're
going to take five suggestions how will
kind of come to you in two segments so
it's fair I'll say if you kind of in
this little Enclave here won't you let's
hear a rap about three-year-old temper
tantrums thank you very much thank you
three-year-old temper tantrum why did
you point at the man next year
Wow a real neither so three-year-old
temper tantrums I love it
this segment here what would you like to
rap about what was that you just said
say it Dave I mean we can get a
different suggestion rather than away
France
[Laughter]
what about Netflix do you have a
particular type of a genre never to
enjoy you do you do not just Netflix and
generals Netflix in general
three-year-old temper tantrums the
middle of the same example that we so
usually read it oh yeah would you like
read back the world series where you can
have you very much you saw a British
press and thought I'll stop them just
don't give me a second on a train
remember what's more that is relevant to
your old temper tantrums the world
series this area won't like student
loans by god I'm not sure of my contract
anything about not going into the area
while we're here in Columbia
I will take the suspension student loans
Netflix the world series three-year-old
temper tantrums final suggestion from
you guys ever had what's it going to be
combination at the same time the
simultaneous shouts of circumcision and
rolling blackouts the challenge of
circumcision during a rolling to go so
there's lovely people the GLS summit at
Columbia University
a freestyle rap made up entirely on the
spot place entirely on those suggestions
never to be seen again never be reversed
no being written and do not worry it'll
not be anywhere near as atrociously
embarrassingly toe-curling to be bad as
you are expecting a privately educated
middle class white boys to be you see
very unconvinced DJ if we can drop that
beat let's get this going you know
before 2012 these
[Music]
perfect wait
I think Caroline's relax sit back Thomas
over I got some Thai snacks
people say Chris what do you feel then I
like to get Netflix and then I start
killing but not killing in a sexual way
that's the [ __ ] term used by the kids to
take money
it is all old-fashioned cept when you
would take your pants off and get less
tense and enjoy what you movies maybe
too protective now on Netflix I really
should check it that's a neat video
property I watch great bridge break off
actually it's amazing my favorite sure
whatever deities now the soul of joy but
they got the new series released it
every Wednesday I was much younger my
friends came to stay I was like what
show do you watch
structure we know a lot of your manager
now this three year old girl had a
temper tantrum it was so horrible that
temple was bulging I was like ah this
problem solving I went to the kitchen
always keep behind the uproar for
Halloween panty this does have satisfied
me it's not dopey no bunch of me I read
make no sense I said please keep up the
pretense that you're having fun
otherwise I'll get fired up will you
make me sing around I won't get I can
find that exit I'm going over there to
Houston the other guys I don't know what
the team's fault
to your surprise I know anything
just like cricket with more shouting all
right the only words about baseball I
can spit tonight let me move up without
precision when it's a black man [ __ ] you
do circumcision if it doesn't make sense
we have to be risk if there's no
electricity to do that Chris you wanna
be careful
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
they wanna keep you in the market or
let's leave and say hey in fact to
hunters now you're like 6 years old are
still on for now
max how the 20 brands that was 10 years
ago I hope you understand I'm still
gonna pay vinyl yet by heaven from the
you pay a while he goes landscape it's
very clever never have to be fun it's
due today it's not that fun the shooters
work around the clock no clothes
covering their mugs the cottage warnings
that was starving the only negative is
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
that is why I do this not not to be a
bull if you understand but the silence
would say I'm gonna do it and you will
go this is going to be a pile of [ __ ]